how are you Rick I'm good richness yeah
this is how the world all comes around
in a big circle you know see you I give
to you you give back to me my lady be on
your radio show it's a circle of life
it's a circle of life that they would
say so how it's interesting I mean the
Cubs and White Sox have only made a
trade 14 times in in their history
should we read into the urgency the fact
that that feel called up the White Sox
for help oh absolutely
the Cubs are one of the biggest failures
this year I mean I put nobody except
Wade Davis in the all-star game it was
unprecedented and he was not on the team
last year so it was unprecedented not to
have a player from World Series champion
not being the all-star game so and the
year before they had seven not seven
starters with seven players including
the whole infield if you recall and so
you know people are still kind of cups
and still kind of high from the buzz of
winning the first World Series in 108
years but then if that wears up that was
as it was wearing off it gets to like
holy smokes is it's the same team you
know I mean on paper it is the same team
and they're there behind the Milwaukee
you know Bucks Brewers right there I
knew nobody takes Milwaukee seriously
here you know and I know that's just as
little fuel to the fire but they had to
do something and this was kind of Theo
Epstein you know second year after the
win his legacy is terrible you know okay
you can get one time sure second stop
that that wasn't the greatest thing ever
but what do you do now and I you know
Robbins Chapman is gone they acquired
him at the end of last year that was a
huge part for them going down the
stretch you know it was like just rented
a bazooka for the you know for the
playoffs and the last I don't know the
month of the season so the coulomb
county has been out there dangling all
season long the White Sox have been in a
rebuild mode and in fact what a lot of
us have given everybody grief orders in
Chicago I just wrote about it yesterday
was it everybody is following all the
other proteins are following the Cubs
plan of carrying their teams down
basically tanking
and we starting all over again so that's
what the Sox are doing they got rid of
Chris Sale you know he starts and yells
to our game that got rid of Adam eat and
they've gotten rid of so many players
but and they're just starting at the
very bottom so the Cubs are not at the
bottom there are purportedly they're at
the top or near the top they got to try
to stay there so guy like Lantana I
started to turn it around he didn't
start out this year very well at all
obviously people here in Chicago watched
him pitch they watched both teams but
you know there's a little bit that
stigma not doing a trade with a teammate
here in town because if that player does
really well well you'll never hear the
end of it from the other fans of the
other team Rick calendar of the Chicago
sun-times joining me here on the show
that said their 9th in Major League
Baseball and total pitching the Cubs is
this is this the fix
I mean how will this I guess shake the
the cobwebs uh no they need to get Kyle
handles back he has not kids like you
device' John West I think the big the
big tipping point he was Jon Lester gave
up 10 runs in the first inning of the
game the other day
Ken I mean it was it was incredible I
was heaps I was getting tuned in the
game a little after it started as like
wait what did I miss like nine innings
or something they didn't but I think
that was there when Lester who is your
you know kind of the star the guy that
feel knew so well that he brought in and
when he has a game like it even it was
just one game he's not been pitching
although well Jake Arrieta has not been
the superstar that he was Wade Davis has
been good you know in relief been real
good but yeah this this hopefully is the
thing that will start they're hitting
going to you know Kyle schwarber has
been a tremendous disappointment but way
too much expectation on the kid I think
and but he came back classic into the
you know at the end of the season for
the very end and for the World Series
and was like them you know Saints for
brought out of the out of the grave and
walking again after that terrible me and
surely nobody expected him back at all
so way too much expectations I think but
hopefully I mean this will work out for
both teams that's what you buy
to see happen these minor leaguers I
mean obviously we don't know that much
about them we haven't seen them
everybody touch like you men as just has
this incredible power we've seen that
before with other players you didn't pan
out to be much so this right hand
kitchen bill and cease and you know
infielders it's as metros and somebody
else I don't know Bryant sleet or
something like that you know I I don't
study the farm team that much but the
Cubs do have a good farm team it seems
like the Sox is getting better so you
know you know if this helps the Cubs
this year this is clearly of this year
thing for the White Sox this is two two
years down the road you think the Cubs
are making the playoffs Rick calendar is
you and I sit here the Thursday before
the second half begins well they got to
beat the Brewers because they're not
gonna make it as a wild-card team and
under 500 oh boy
got about it yes that's a topless I mean
my image quick-thinking you know they're
not going to but I just I just to go
from the World Series and not making the
playoff with the same team essentially
without really really major injuries I
mean that's crazy isn't it mmm I it is I
honestly thought they had one of the
best chances to repeat of any team that
I've seen win the World Series just
because of how you young they are and
how good they were at every position and
how terrific their manager is and how
setup they were in a farm system in case
anybody faltered that they could bring
somebody up I was concerned about their
closing and yet they got a guy who wound
up being the lone cub to the all-star
game albeit the eventual loosing pitcher
which I guess just shows you how the cub
seasons gone so far right yeah yeah it
really does you know one thing about a
World Series championship every player
as you look back on it has either a very
good year or as best year ever
and how those things all come together
is kind of magic you know and don't
forget the Cubs head as good as they
were they had to go to extra innings in
the seventh game of the World Series
against a depleted Indians team just to
win we may have given them too much
you know they did they got it to such an
astounding start last year just amazing
ages were way all the way through and
people were reached just crazy the whole
year you know breaking this hundred
eight-year curse that you know I I don't
know if there's small injuries we'll
find out about what the pitches if guy
suddenly got just a little bit older you
know Ben Zobrist hasn't been gradients a
World Series MVP uh you know Chris Brian
the MVP of the National League didn't
make the all-star game you know those
are those are things that I don't know
maybe uh you know just a few guys that
they they got rid of that changed you
know players that didn't seem to matter
that much might have made the difference
but it's really a kind of a just pure
chemistry it might have also been killed
Madden's year just for everything
working just like for him he might not
be a great manager coming off of a
championship some managers need to build
toward something you know I and that'd
be no discredit to him whatsoever but I
think there are managers for all kinds
of teams at all kinds of seasons mm-hmm
before I let you go Rick Rick toner to
the Chicago sun-times I would be remiss
if I didn't ask you about Dan Hamptons
comments that if Jay Cutler was on the
mid-80s bears they would have won four
championships I asked that of Brian
Urlacher about forty minutes ago and he
said Dan Hamptons entitled to his
opinion the Hampton McMahon shoot is
just one for all times it's just it's
just wonderful he doesn't like Jim
McMahon and I don't know did look bad he
just kind of you know spits or whatever
Dodd knows but that's hilarious
you know you talked to Brian Urlacher
earlier and I don't know if you know
Richard his brother is he was or maybe
still is the mayor of a small town right
around here benoît and they look exactly
like brian is well not now that bond has
got all that hair but they did look
identical except Casey your whole act is
just a smaller addition to buy and he
actually played middle linebacker at
Lake Forest College so the Bears were
practicing you know right there and like
for us and Casey's over there and it's
like it's hilarious I like Brian a lot
but dan Hampton I love gave Hampton so
so
why doesn't Hampton like McMahon why
would that be a problem I mean didn't -
why doesn't he like yeah why would he
use later bash him like that oh god it
goes back it goes back to 85 whatever
defense hated the offense first of all
you know that buddy Ryan got carried out
the field every day they didn't hate him
they I know they had lot disdain for
them and you know there were fights
between offense and defense
Jim Kolbert and was a classic between
covert and who cut who was one of one of
the nuts not the fridge but somebody and
you know it got really really nasty and
so I think that Hampton being a you know
Hall of Fame defensive play on on that
team just picked up on McMahon didn't
like his attitude what do you like the
fact he got hurt I think that might have
been the biggest thing it McMahon really
did get her he was just incredibly
Cutler Cutler went shopping on a bum
knee the week after he couldn't finish
an NFC Championship game against the
Packers Rick yeah well and so he's come
to suck it up rub some dirt on it I'm
telling you no so why would Hampton
being in Cutler's corner over McMahon
uh I don't think he's in colors corner I
think he's just not in McMahon okay man
I just love this old ancient rivalries
that just pop up days later and they get
together you know the 85 Bears will
still come together and you know
everybody knows there's animosity and
all that but they don't come together
it's just part of the deal
I'm sure Hansen to tell McMahon to stage
Europe's Europe you know you guys all
you guys it's very amusing I got to tell
you you know nothing personal Oh Rick
thanks for calling and I appreciate it
we appreciate I really sense that's Rick
telander with the Chicago point of view
in the day that the White Sox and Cubs
pull off the 14th all-time trade between
the two of them the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint